this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery of the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's heading to a galaxy far
far away to look at the weapons of star
wars battlefront 2.
ah the e11 blaster rifle it was the
blaster that i wanted as a kid and here
is one
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to video game firearms make
sure to hit that subscribe button
and if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down
let us know in the comments section
below if you'd like to help out the
royal army's museum and continue to
support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
okay paul's there right well i would say
the iconic dl-44 iconic for its use by
han solo which
it clearly wasn't meant to be in any way
unique to him
in the original movies luke famously
famously but obviously
carries one as well it isn't unique to
him in the star wars universe it is
unique to him in battlefront 2 i believe
it is of course a mauser c96 an mg81
machine gun muzzle booster
stuck to a chunky barrel
and a scope mount stuck to the side one
more thing
that's occurred to me is the shooting
position that he uses
both in the movies and in games is that
hyper exaggerated
james bond one-handed shooting hand out
to the side pose
now this this was um common in the 70s
and 80s
it was actually taught by people like
the fbi for revolver shooting which was
all about balance
you're supposed to lower your center of
gravity lean forward throw your throw
your support what would be your support
arm
out the balance look where you're
shooting not bother about looking down
the site
i always love um reflections of the real
world
in my fiction and i thought that's an
interesting one to point out
right another heavily disguised weapon
and this is so this is the a180 sniper
as you can probably see from the from
the model if you haven't played the game
before or
seen the film rogue one if you haven't
you should there is in fact a luger
p08 pistol embedded somewhere in this
sniper rifle
now in the star wars universe we can
stick a longer barrel and a stock
on something and turn it into a sniper
rifle in the real world
can't really do that so i remember
distinctly from from the
from rogue one um jyn erso's what
immediately popped into my head when i
saw that scene was it's a space luger
with enough sort of built up parts on it
to make it look distinctly different
the sniper rifle version which that
we're seeing in the game here
well the most notable thing apart from
it being made out of beluga
is the slightly comedy telescopic barrel
a way to keep this sort of hybrid weapon
compact i suppose um in the real world
we have various ways to do that
uh take down rifles is probably how we
make a takedown version so the barrel
comes off maybe the stock comes off as
well
but instead they went for something
visually interesting and
we pull the barrel out to extend it and
that wouldn't work with a
conventional firearm obviously because
you can't
telescope barrels into themselves
because only one section
is going to be of the right diameter for
the bullet for a blaster
who knows although there is an important
safety tip from the um the animation in
the game
where the character extends the barrel
they've just done what i've done
with it unloaded and cleared luger i
hasten to add
but that's a live firearm they pull out
the barrel with their hand over the
muzzle so i hope they have good
trigger discipline in the star wars
universe because you do not want to
shoot
a hole through your hand
[Music]
the the t21 usually called a heavy
blaster i think
and it's pretty obviously a lewis light
machine gun
of the first world war period which i
have here
which is extremely heavy i've got it
because i want to show you
the really the only modification that
they made for the film and
carried through to the games all that's
happening is
the pan magazine that's
normally used well always used with the
lewis gun otherwise you haven't got any
bullets
is just taken off and thrown away and as
you can see from the
the in-game model it's a pretty faithful
replica of what's under the lewis gun
magazine including parts of the
mechanism that are specifically for
cartridges that don't exist in the star
wars universe or at least not anymore
so you've got when you know the guns and
you're looking at them you think
oh what does that feature do in this
reality because
in real reality it's all about feeding
cartridges into a gun
i have i do remember from screenshots
from the movie little details
like modifications that were made during
the first world war
this device here which you see in
certainly in the movie
this is an oil bottle so that the gunner
would always have
an oil bottle to hand who knows what
that does
in the star wars universe
[Music]
ah the e11 blaster rifle for me this
this is
the star wars gun it's the stormtroopers
standard issue
weapon of course and our heroes in the
original trilogy
get their hands on them pretty early on
and use them for quite a lot of that
film
it was the blaster that i wanted as a
kid and
here is one well sort of this is the
canadian c1 version of the sterling
submachine gun and i'm showing you this
because it's the version that we see in
battlefront 2.
the the actual guns used in return of
the jedi because that's the version
that's being replicated here
were japanese model guns so toys
effectively replicas and they were what
was readily available and legally
convenient so those are what were
dressed up as e11s for
return of the jedi i suppose the only
other thing i'd just mention is a bit on
the um
the prop design of the original gun
because we're fortunate enough to have
one of the original e11s from
the original star wars movies and the
components that have been put on there
are
mostly original components with one
notable exception which is the
um machine copier counter box that sits
on the side of ours
these are over in the museum so i can't
show them to you but come and see us
uh that box there was added by lucasfilm
because
our two guns our rebel blaster and our
imperial blaster were loaned
by by bapti um who created them where
they were rebuilt and they were loaned
back to lucasfilm
for reference to develop the f11d
for the first order so what did they do
briefly um
they they stuck stuff to it they stuck a
strip of metal into the cooling
hole here and then attached it to the
rear sight
and clamped a sherman tank optical
optical sight
to that they uh put draw runners
hardware store drawer runners from bmq i
i gather from
our uk viewers stuck those into the
cooling holes that disguises the cooling
holes
and the other key thing to stop it
looking like a 1950 submachine gun with
this curved 34 round magazine sticking
out the side
was a short magazine for the c1 there
was in fact
for the canadian c1 there was in fact a
short magazine made
so it already looks a bit like an e11
very interesting when we move to the
first order f11d
which we saw there as well the black and
white one in that and i don't think you
see this in the movies but i've seen it
on the real props that i've seen
they redesigned this as sort of part of
the receiver of the gun
the the stock and then what should be
the shoulder stock
is a foregrip that you can flip down
like this and out of the front pops a
little flashlight
that was a really neat piece of design
albeit
a little bit dangerous because you might
blast your fingers off and so that's
that's the evolution
of the e11
this is an interesting change of pace
the cycler rifle
this is introduced in the star wars
movies as
a sort of sci-fi fantasy parallel of
what it's based on
which is um afghan gizelle the sort of
middle east north africa part of the
world
where in the 19th century the british
army with
relatively advanced small arms ran into
tribesmen in the hills using
traditionally made
muzzleloading rifles called the caldera
gizale
and that's what the the the sand people
being are parallel to
sort of nomadic human peoples who are
maybe not technologically hugely
sophisticated but
know their environment know their
territory and are able to
fight more sophisticated more numerous
enemies and
come out on top and so that that weapon
which is
the only projectile weapon possibly in
the whole of the star wars canon
although i'm sure someone will correct
me there but um certainly in the game
that that's an interesting historical
earth parallel
to what we see in star wars universe
with the cyclo rifles in in the various
forms of star wars media
adds some much needed variety to the
roster of
laser guns in the game
so that's um what we've seen there is a
fairly
non-traditional weapon for star wars
what it is mostly an m60 machine gun
which
which fits the star wars tradition of
modifying real world guns
to turn them into some sci-fi fantasy
blaster that
that fits and so i i must admit i
initially thought that this was a video
game only
weapon but um as is often the case it's
based on something from elsewhere in the
franchise
and in this case it it's it fits very
well
for for what the real gun is the m60 was
and is often to be found as a helicopter
door gun and we see it in rogue one in
that role that's clearly what it was
conceived
for for that movie here of course we're
using it in the ground roll
so it's a nice bit of um original
trilogy
design work that albeit it pushes the
timeline slightly further forwards
but not by much
uh now this is this is a weapon that
i've not seen before
because i to my shame i've never seen
the clone wars series where it
apparently first appeared um so the
iqa11
is a clone wars era sniper rifle and it
is
from from the first person view very
reminiscent of the accuracy
international
pm or l96a1 sniper rifle from our
reality but actually if you look at the
the 3d model it's quite different it's
got a different design of thumb hole
stock
the whole silhouette is actually quite
different and i think that's because
it if it's originally designed for an
animated series that has quite simple
shapes going on then they're not going
to stick too closely to the realistic
look of the gun whereas your typical
star wars gun
is a real gun covered in stuff as we've
established so it's as filtered through
the medium of animation
and then appearing in the realistic
themed
battlefront 2 game where it looks more
like a real
gun sort of but it still has the
heritage of having been designed as a
as a piece of concept art so it's an odd
one out in those respects i think
so we also saw um the sort of handheld
i think it's meant to be an ion weapon a
stun gun a shock blaster
famously used by the jawas to
incapacitate
anything i suppose
[Music]
and um that was a really obvious bit of
movie gun casting because you could
you could readily see that this was a
short magazine lee enfield
with the stock party cut down and the
barrel cut down
and then with the first world war
vintage
designed grenade launcher cup fitted to
the end of the barrel
to create a radically different look but
it's still very obviously a bolt action
rifle
now this is not the jawa
blaster but it's very similar it's also
a cut down
smle rifle and then we've got this
recoil hook
at the front for hooking over
something and i suspect that something
is the side of an armored vehicle
because this is this is a smoke grenade
launcher
and anything that's large and heavy like
that that you're firing out of something
relatively small and light has a lot of
recoil perhaps the uh
makers of the mandalorian are watching
this and would like a new
weapon to feature in the series uh feel
free to steal this design
we are a museum as you know the royal
armouries if you'd like to to donate
absolutely no pressure to do so but
there are links in the description
also for our membership scheme i have a
book out at the moment on british
bullpup firearms
you might like to check that out we've
also started doing
a series of short videos on our own
youtube youtube channel
at royal armouries the first one of
which anyway complements what we're
doing
here with the guys at gamespot so feel
free to check out our youtube channel
as well thanks very much
[Music]
you